the force will be with Disney this year
Morgan Stanley predicting that the
newest star wars film will be the third
highest grossing movie of all time and
generate 1 billion dollars for Disney's
bottom line Ben Swinburne wrote the
report he's a managing director at
Morgan Stanley and he joins us now from
their offices in New York so Ben this
Star Wars movie as you said would be the
third highest grossing movie of all time
but not enough to topple James Cameron
as self-declared king of the world yeah
i mean i think our report really makes
three main points the first is we are
quite bullish on Star Wars and why
wouldn't you be there's incredible
anticipation for the film and you have
Disney's global merchandise and
marketing power behind it the second is
putting the movie in context as big as
that is a billion dollars over the
ten-year ultimate of the film we're
still talking about only a six percent
contribution to their net income and
earnings per share for fiscal 16 and
remind people that over half of Disney's
earnings come from their media networks
mainly ESPN and ABC where we're much
more cautious from a sector perspective
we have a cautious view on the media
industry so you're buying Disney stock
at a 25-percent premium to the peer
group and as bullish as we are about
Star Wars we think that's relatively
priced into expectations it's priced
into expectations so given all of that
what's the biggest risk to Star Wars not
performing up to expectations and
disappointing investors if you look at
the breakdown of the movie profitability
domestically we think it'll actually be
the second highest grossing or tied for
the second highest-grossing domestic box
office film you've got titanic and
avatar as one and two and then really
international is kind of the interesting
question how well will star wars do
internationally we've seen a major
increase in international box office
results for big tentpole films over the
last few years and we raised our
expectations for the international
growth in this note and the last piece
is merchandise we think the film will
lift Disney's global merchandise retail
sales to about 5 billion for Lucasfilm
properties which obviously generates a
nice licensing revenue stream for
but again all that looks pretty well
priced into the multiple and
expectations for this up right certainly
people who can see out to what that will
bring when you talk about the
merchandising revenue from Star Wars
certainly it'll be big internationally
especially how does that compare to stay
frozen which Disney has built into a
nice franchise on its own without having
to pay any kind of licensing yeah we
think Star Wars is bigger but you know
Star Wars could be one of the top if not
number one global merchandise brands
certainly in the year after the film we
think currently with no movie out in the
market it's doing about three billion of
somewhere between two and a half and
three billion of gross global retail
sales already for the Star Wars
properties so it's already a powerhouse
so we think the movie obviously will
drive incremental revenue once the movie
comes out later this year in December
just to put this all into perspective
here Ben disney bought lucasfilm in 2012
for just over four billion dollars
what's the math on how much this film
will cost to produce and then to also
market and at what point does the
purchase really pay for itself yeah it's
a good question i mean you could also
throw Marvel in the mix there which they
also paid about four billion or even
going back to Pixar between six and
seven billion you know these films on
their own generate reasonable returns
but it's hard to analyze the returns on
these investments about thinking about
all the derivative income they're
generating at the theme parks and other
parts of their properties to answer your
question specifically we think Star Wars
to make and market is somewhere between
four and five hundred million dollars
for 500 million how does that compare to
some of the other big blockbuster
franchises it's at the top of the heap I
mean there there's there's probably very
few films that are going to cost more
than that if we ever do get another
avatar from James Cameron I think you'll
see that number higher than the Star
Wars number oh yeah James needs to stay
king of the world giving all your
caution been on Disney does izzy need to
use its cash flow for acquisitions or
other investments rather than on share
buybacks I believe it's spent what 32
billion dollars on saw stock buyback
since 2007 yeah you know Disney has
actually pared back their buyback
activity lately and compared to their
peer group as a percent of market cap
they actually are buying back less stock
than the other media companies I think
they've done a nice job balancing their
cap
allocation between dividends which they
raised recently quite a bit buybacks and
acquisitions I think the tough challenge
in the media business right now is what
do you buy there's clearly clear head
winds to the television business when
you whether you look at ratings
cord-cutting there's no easy solution to
sort of buy your way out of that so
really owning powerful brands powerful
IP is key Disney's already they're kind
of hard to find that out there in the
market from an acquisition perspective
yeah there just aren't that many
Marvel's or lucasfilm's around I went
back to ESPN and what you said about how
that really is the the bulk of Disney's
business you talk about modest
subscriber erosion in your note and
tough comp so it sounds like a pretty
mature business in need of a catalyst
yeah you know ESPN obviously an
incredible profit engine for Disney an
incredibly important network for
distributors in the pay-tv space but not
everybody watches sports and as we think
about the future of the pay TV bundle we
think we're going to see these skinnier
bundles emerged less networks being
distributed maybe more ala carte options
for consumers and I think you'll see
pressure on subscribers and for ESPN all
their sports liabilities are fixed so
they owe the league's money whether they
have 100 million subscribers or 70 so as
we watch this business of all over time
that's going to be really important to
track how the subscriber numbers in the
bundle evolve against the fixed cost
base all right thank you so much Ben
Swinburne really fascinating stuff Ben
Swinburne is with Morgan Stanley